good morning John it is 2015 meaning
nothing the orbit of the earth is an
ellipse
there's no point on it that is the
beginning of that if the Earth's day has
nothing to do with the Earth's year we
catch a glimpse of this when we wake up
in the morning an exhilarating New
Year's in Australia or I well I mean
what it but come on the perils of living
in a global culture John we don't get to
ignore all the seemingly fundamental
things that are actually totally
arbitrary and just made up so that's
what I'm gonna talk about today here on
the second day of 2015 different lists
of things that seemed intractable but
are totally made up
gender named Alison hazel Ashley Carroll
they all seem like girl names to us but
a hundred years ago they were more
commonly used for boys alphabetical
order there's nothing special about a
that makes ago first the alphabet
seemingly just completely randomly
ordered all the vowels are mixed in most
commonly used letters are at the
beginning and the end there are some
things that have order like UV and W are
together because they were all once one
letter the interesting thing about this
completely arbitrary order of letters
though is that we've been using it
roughly the same for over 3,000 years
that's longer than any of the words in
our language have existed and if you're
wondering why they're in that order
no one knows face 10 when we count we do
zero one two three four five six seven
eight nine and then we get to 10 and we
take the 1 again and put a zero after it
there's no reason why that has to happen
at 10 it could happen at 12 it could
happen at 18 it could happen at 3
aground at 5 binary is when it happens
just after the zero in the one base 10
isn't special at all it's actually
probably more annoying than some other
systems we could use base 12 might be
better we in fact use base 12 about we
talked about dozens probably we use base
10 just because we have 10 fingers
that's three that's the reason bugs are
gross the culinary preferences of
different cultures are wildly diverse
now we think that the idea of consuming
a grub is just not this bad but 80% of
studied cultures eat insects so we are
in fact the weird ones hats are cute
lots of cultures think that we are crazy
for letting animals live inside of our
house and when my dog comes in from the
yard after stepping in her own poop I
kind of agree with them dirty dancing if
the pole is horizontal
that's gymnastics if the pole is
vertical and stripping guys you saw I
can't wear skirts
absolutely no reason why men's legs have
to be confined to separate cloth
cylinders of course I have seen this
norm broken but not without feeling that
little bit of like wow this is weird
feeling that you get when you see an arm
being broken money this is a piece of
paper it's a very fancy piece of paper
but it's just this is a piece of paper
do something there's nothing that make
this worth $20 except that we just sort
of agreed it feels weird of me when I
see these two dollar bills which are
worth two dollars like they're
legitimate currency but they look fake
to me they look like they know weirdly
enough I like two dollar bills
I hate one dollar bills tattoos it's
just cuz they're weird even weirder
nowadays there's actually a number on a
hard drive somewhere then that's the
thing that decides whether or not I can
buy food or a house or Tesla or a yacht
this video is just a few silly examples
but by forming our language culture very
literally controls our thoughts we can't
think with words that we don't have it's
hard to separate yourself enough from
culture to be able to examine it if
you'd separate yourself too much it
could be really uncomfortable I have
been there I did is we need culture we
need norms we need there to be an order
to the alphabet and for there to be a
first day of the year there's some bits
that while being convenient are not
innocuous and it is our job to pick
those out and say you don't belong here
anymore that's something that we can do
but only if we take the time to step
back and examine our culture which is
best done by examining other people's
culture which is why if you can you
should study broadly and deeply and
watch crash course world history at all
of crash course and also scishow and
yeah okay John thank you for your
amazing video on racism this week if
people haven't seen it you can go check
it out you do become slash flog brothers
that's where we're at okay John I'll see
you on Tuesday